hey what's up I'm Kristen hi I'm Naomi
and I'm Ella and we are here today to
take the which Charlie's Angel are you
quiz
how would your BFF describe you
we've got honest loyal funny kind
creative adventurous all of the above
depends on which friend you're asking
are you okay I'd say you
you're definitely loyal I'd say your
your loyal human being I would do
anything for you yeah I agree
oh okay can you take it with it right
all right this guy your kind man period
like honestly one of the nicest people
you make this one a matter of mercy
you're kind that's it I'll go with the
roast me oh you're an adventurous girl I
hate you all right take a weapon laser
gun lipstick hand grenade Hill
switchblade glasses rocket launcher
rings boom pepper spray pocketwatch
nerve gas that person of course that's a
goalie in his hands I go straight in
with that rocket launcher ring I knew
you were gonna say I knew that finger
theme song to dramatically we got
independent women by Destiny's Child
roar by Katy Perry confident by Demi
Lovato who dot yellow by cardi B I know
break free by Ariana Grande and fill in
myself by Nicki Minaj and Beyonce more
so I do right although I like roar - I
really do yeah like that song yeah you
will because you love the rule I'm going
with Katy yeah you should do it I'm
gonna hit that boat yellow
yes I'm gonna hit independent women
destinies pick a place to relax after a
mission okay
I've never been in Bora Bora the Amalfi
Coast is gorgeous what sir Linda's
really up yes Switzerland is Tokyo I
would go to Switzerland I think okay a
little mountain yeah situation engine I
think I'm gonna go Bora Bora
just girls when we go to Tokyo for the
first time I'm a feeling we all might
find ourselves in Tokyo together yeah
dang stick a code word for puzzle looper
yabba-dabba-doo dunder poppy or flugel
bum puzzle all the way I'm like ma Abba
Dabba for sure I've heard like done that
there's like yeah that's usually done
don't just seems like a really good name
for a tech company but the puzzle come
in under the ever dude right okay which
Elizabeth Banks movie are you washing
tonight four year old virgin Hunger
Games pitch perfect role models Zack and
Miri Make a Porno
11 love and mercy is one of my favorite
movies Zack and Miri Make a Porno is
also more fun to watch after a long day
at work like yeah I'm gonna go with role
models cuz I think that movies hilarious
I think I'm gonna do 40 year old virgin
cuz I just got off I believe all of
these movies yeah shout out to you Edie
love narcy's incredible okay
she's so good at it but you Oh Jane oh
my daddy now and you're Jane Kona
because exactly I go because I show him
this is because I chose love and mercy
if I had chosen was that give me a
remake of were my first instinct I would
have yeah yes this is a faulty you know
you know what it is
here it is if you put angel ounces
you'll saw a train your trainers yeah
yeah yeah Frank yeah yeah that was so
much fun thank you for having us
BuzzFeed our movies up yeah yeah it's
calls dick Charlie my big news
[Music]